you asked on Twitter would you rather
have 10 million dollars or 10 million
subscribers on YouTube uh what would
your own answer be at various stages in
your career if uh if if I had nothing I
would say 10 million dollars so because
with 10 million dollars you can hire
some people and pump out content with
like a million or two get 10 million
subscribers and then keep the other 8
million so that's if you believe in your
ability to grow a channel if you uh well
if you yeah if you don't believe in your
ability to grow a channel then you
shouldn't take the 10 million
subscribers because you're just gonna
kill the channel so the 10 million is
definitely a better question would be
would you rather have a million dollars
or 10 million subscribers that's where
it gets a little tricky because now it's
like hmm you know a million dollars
life-changing amount of money uh but you
know if you Sim I know what you're doing
you probably make a million dollars off
a 10 million subscriber Channel but it
is a little bit a million dollars might
not be enough to to build a strong team
because you don't know how to do it so
you might waste all that money yeah or
they just keep it and retire yeah okay
that's true yeah because 10 million's
just so high it's like just never work
again who cares for the average human
that's so much money it's interesting to
me also do the value of the subscriber
versus the value of the dollar
um I suppose how valuable is a
subscriber for
uh like what percentage of the videos
like how active are the subscribers and
watching the video
um
for you that's hard I don't know I was
actually thinking more about the
subscriber to Dollar like if someone has
10 million subscribers have they made 10
million dollars I don't know why that
that kind of popped in my head it's an
interesting thought
uh do you ever when you analyze uh
videos do you ever analyze videos like
we've talked about offline of other
videos across the YouTube in general
just to understand trying to understand
social behavior all your not all but a
lot of the questions are analytics based
yeah yeah it's still because I love it
uh I mean it's just a giant social
experiment right like what people like
to watch what people share yeah it's
like a fascinating so I hate that so
like I said before what percentage of
your audience do you think care about
this kind of stuff like this deeply
about YouTube Analytics I think a large
amount care about
uh curiosity and exploration of
interesting ideas so in that sense yeah
this would this was fitted I love it
this is funny this isn't me like trying
to like I I love you and I actually I
love future Magnus one and I um and even
your Hikaru one was really good a bunch
of other ones but I think we're getting
to the point now where only analytics
junkies would want to keep hearing more
analytics talk and the Normie is
probably like they've had their dose of
YouTube talk for the next three years
maybe I'm wrong hey comment if I'm wrong
I could be I don't know your audience
see this is where you would tell me Shut
up I know my audience you dumbass and I
don't at all I actually I just follow
the threat of curiosity
and I think there's just a lot of
curious humans in the world and and to
me it's like
so the question about analytics is the
question of basically stepping away
stepping outside of yourself and
thinking why the hell do I like Tick
Tock so much why do I like Twitter so
much why do I like YouTube so much and
getting even if you're not a Creator
getting an insight into that is really
interesting
it's like what
uh because because all these platforms
are fundamentally changing the nature of
content people are reading books less
they're probably going to be watching
movies less and less they're probably
going to be watching Netflix less and
less